في فقرتنا الصحيه رمضانيه نتعمق اليوم في
فوائد الصيام على جيناتنا البشريه والحديث
محوره على الكثير من الدراسات عن علاقه
الصيام باطاله العمر الافتراضي النظام
الغذائي الذي يعتمد على الصيام المتقطع
والطعام المقيد بجدول زمني له تاثير على
جينات مهمه للانسان تلعب دورا كبيرا في
الاستجابه لمختلف الانظمه الغذائيه
دراسه جديده اجراها باحثون مهدي سولت
للدراسات البيولوجيه في امريكا اجرت على
الفئران اظهرت ان الوجبات المقيده بوقت
محدد نشطت الجينات في اكثر من اثنتين
وعشرين منطقه بالجسم والدماغ هذه
الاستجابه تعادل 70% من الجينات لدى
الانسان دراسه وجدت ان هذا النظام له
فوائد محتمله بما في ذلك الوقايه من مرض
السكري وامراض القلب وارتفاع ضغط الدم
وحتى السرطان لكن يتوقف ذلك ايضا على نمط
الحياه سنتعرف اكثر حول تاثير الصيام
ونشاطه على الجينات مع لميس ابراهيم اليك
يا لميس
في دراسه اجريت على الفئران عام 2021 وجدت
ان بعض الانماط الجينيه كانت مسؤوله ان
تعيش الفئران لفتره اطول عند تقييد فترات
اطعامها بمواعيد محدده دراسه اخرى لعام
2019 وجدت ان توقف عن الطعام لمده التراوح
بين 12 و16 ساعه يمكن ان يزيد من افرازه
هرمون الجريلين وهو المسؤول عن احساسنا
بالجوع والذي بدوره يحفز تكوين خلايا
دماغيه جديده
الصيام ايضا مسؤول عن تحسين الادراك
والمزاج العام حيث يمكن ايضا ان يبطئ
التدهور في وظائف المخ ويقي من مرض
الزهايمر كما ان التوقف عن الطعام لفترات
محدده يمكن ان يقلل من مستويات القلق
واحتمالات الاصابه من الاضطرابات العصبيه
وفقا لدراسه نشرت عام 2013 حيث اظهر ثلاثه
اطفال مصابين بالصرع خضعوا للصيام المتقطع
تحسنا في السيطره على النوبات
[موسيقى]
وتنورنا في الاستوديو اليوم دكتوره مريم
مطر رئيس الجمعيه الامارات الامارات
الجينيه ومركز الشيخ زايد الابحاث الجينيه
دكتوره يسعد مساكي رمضان كريم اهلا بك
معنا مساكم الله كل خير وتتبارك ايامكم
الدكتوره اليوم نتحدث عن الصيام المتقطع
وتاثير عجينه الانسان هل بالفعل هناك
علاقه بين الجانبين بس خلينا نركز بعد ان
احنا اليوم نتكلم عن الصيام بالعموم
والصوم والصوم هذا اللي احنا نسويه فيه
رمضان ان احنا نمتنع تماما عن الماكل
والمشرب اما الصيام المتقطع تقدرين في
فتره الصيام تاخذين تشربين ماي تاخذين
شاهي قهوه بس المهم انه ما يكون في سكريات
فبالتالي احنا كاطباء كنا نعرف انه الصيام
يؤثر بتاثير ايجابي على الجسم بس ما كنا
نعرف شو هي الاليه وين كان يتاثر الحين مع
التقدم في العلوم وتقدم في الفحوصات عرفنا
ان كل هذا يصير على مستوى علم فوق الجينات
اللي هي المفاتيح اللي احنا نقدر نتحكم
فيها من خلال النمط المعيشي طيب خلينا
نفهم ولو بدنا نركز اكثر ونخصص ما هي
الجينات التي يؤثر عليها الصوم ايجابا
ونتحدث هنا بانه يزيد من فعاليتها وما هي
الجينات التي يؤثر عليها الصوم بان يحد
منها يخمدها ان صح التعبير لكي تنعكس
ايجابا ايضا على الكسر خلينا نبدا بدايه
بالاعضاء في جسم الانسان ونتكلم عن الدماغ
اليوم احنا نعرف مع التقدم في العمر في
اشياء كثير تتغير في الدماغ وفي مواد
معينه تتراكم اليوم العلم اثبت ان في
جينات معينه خاصه من خلال علم فوق الجينات
يتم تحفيزها واللي هي تمنع تراكم ماده
الامايولويت هاي اللي تسبب الزهايمر في
كثير من الناس اضافه الى بعض من الجينات
اللي لها ارتباط مباشر بنشاط زائد في
الدماغ واللي ممكن لا سمح الله الزيت
مضاعفات امراض نفسيه خاصه بالاخص
كان الاكتئاب او حتى الفرح مثل نوع من
انواع الاضطرابات النفسيه اللي تصير في
الانسان اضافه الى جينا كثير مهمه فوق علم
فوق الجينات اللي هي لها علاقه بالساعه
البيولوجيه وخاصه للناس اللي عندهم
مناوبات احنا نعرف انه اليوم اذا واحد
وظيفته فيها كثير من المناوبات هذه تؤثر
على الساعه البيولوجيه والاهم من ذلك
للاسف تسوي كثير من مضاعفات الاخبار
فبالتالي اليوم اثبت العلم ان الناس اللي
يكون عندهم كثير من مناوبات وعندهم
يلتزمون بالصيام المتقطع مرتين في الاسبوع
هذا يقلل اضرار المناوبات على صحتهم وخاصه
على الساعه البيولوجيه ونظام الساعه
البيولوجيا
يقال كذلك انه الصيام يطهر الجسم من
الفيروسات يحميه من الالتهابات ويساعد في
اعاده تدوير البروتينات المتضرره الى عماد
هذا صحيح هذا كثير صحيح وخاصه في عمليه
هذه عمليه الجسم يقوم فيها انه يتخلص من
البروتينات القديمه من الفضلات اللي
موجوده في الجسم من خلايا معينه وهذه
العمليه كثير تحفز في فتره الصيام
فبالتالي تزيد المناعه لدى جسم الانسان
واريد الى الجينات اللي يتم كذلك تحفيزها
في الصوم وبالاخص ارتفاع الكوليسترول
وجينا اللي لها علاقه باضطراب السكرين تقل
المستقبلات ونشاطها على الخليه فبالتالي
اليوم بالعموم اي نوع من الصيام سواء كان
الصوم او الصيام ليه تاثير ايجابي على
مستوى علم فوق الجينات وهذا فتح لنا باب
جدا رائع للدراسات اللي من خلالها نقدر
نعالج هذه الاضطرابات مش من خلال الادويه
ولكن من خلال ايوه خلال تغيير نمط المعيشه
الدكتوره مريم اليوم بين الصوم وبين
الصيام هل فعلا يؤثر الصوم على الحد من
الشيخوخه وبنسبه 60% كما قرانا طبعا ويمكن
هذه المقاله انا شاركتكم فيها عشان كانت
قبل في سنه 2011 كانت فقط هذه المعلومه
موجوده في فئران التجارب بعدين لما اخذنا
عينه كبيره من البشر شاركوا فيها كانت
العينه فوق 3000 من الناس اللي اعمارهم
فوق الخمسين سنه وتم بشكل ملاحظه وفحص هذه
المؤشر شفنا ان هذه الطفره تم تثبيطها
اللي تساعد على شيخوخه الخليه وتزيد العمر
البيولوجينا نصوم حتى بعد رمضان مرتين في
الاسبوع شكرا جزيلا لك حدثتينا في
الاستوديو دكتوره رئيسه جمعيه الامراض
الجينيه ومركز الشيخ زايد الابحاث الجينيه